you know i did a local show here on
channel 11 on fox 11 all through the
pandemic we were doing updates every day
what was going on and we had friends
somebody from the school board come in
you know weekend when they decided they
were going to close the schools and i
was like how did you arrive at this
decision who were the physicians that
advised you who were the ex we just
decided to do it it's like
why how long what are the consequences
how are you you should see now the data
there's this group called gaggle that
documents the data of adverse events
from the
use of screens in terms of sexting
access to porn violent violent and
suicidal sort of uh musing online it's
like up 400 percent and it's up in in
elementary age as well as middle school
all right i'm in studio with a live a
real live human being
according to the paperwork dr drew
pinsky it is good to see you my friend
good to see you and i i to be fair i
insisted on this i did you were like no
we'll do it by zoom i'm like no i don't
want to do it by zoom anymore i'm tired
of this i've seen this great studio i
want to be in it with you i want to see
you it's good to see ya we are less than
six feet apart so we're risking
everything right now you're risking
everything i'm as immune as i can
possibly be you've had covered like 18
times
i've had the antibodies i've had the
injection i've had the vaccine i'm good
and i do something that no one does i'm
following a very sophisticated antibody
screen with my neutralizing antibodies
and my b cell function so i can tell you
categorically if i get a cova to be
reportable do you feel like your life's
work has led to this moment no i don't i
never expected any of this nor do i
really welcome it to be fair but uh but
i i will you know i took the johnson
johnson vaccine myself and i had a nasty
reaction to it really bad i woke up with
a sudden black eye which is called a
raccoon's eye which is the presenting
symptom of transverse sinus thrombosis
which is the dreaded complication
of the uh johnson johnson factory i'm
looking in the mirror going oh god damn
it am i gonna have a transverse sinus
thrombosis and nothing so and nothing
take another one did you choose the john
cena johnson
i sort of picked it early for two
reasons one i i react horribly to
viruses horribly to vaccines so i kind
of just wanted one vaccine
silly me now i need another but uh i i
was hoping just to get by with one also
i like the idea of a sort of an
old-fashioned platform and nothing
against maduro i might even take the
modern now or the our mrna vaccines but
i just thought
i react to everything better i use some
old-fashioned so before we get to the
book which i'm holding in my hands i'll
put it down for a moment let's just do
the the coveted stuff yeah just trying
to get it out
you've got antibodies you did johnson
and johnson you don't have a problem
with mrna
is there anything that people should
know about the mrna
is you know we're hearing so much
conflicting stuff and i had dr brian
keating on my show last night last week
talking about that people just don't
trust experts anymore and in many cases
it's the expert's fault right so
particularly the cdc's fault i mean and
the government anybody associated with
public health or cdc has created vaccine
hesitancy they've created it they've
done everything wrong they should have
been from the beginning wide open here's
our thinking here's our concerns here's
the debate we have behind closing here
the all that is how you get people who
are resistant to loosen up and come on
board you treat them like intelligent
people who need to be reasoned with and
you give them all the information you
don't say you can't handle the truth you
can't handle the truth i don't i become
resistant
when what's bizarre to me
is we we
learned how to do this during the hiv
epidemic do you i don't know if i ever
told you this i got involved in radio
because
in 1983 one anthony fauci who was my
hero at the time was telling us young
physicians that we had to get out there
and educate and change behavior because
we didn't we couldn't get people to stop
having sex and passing this virus and i
thought
i took it very seriously and we learned
across that that pandemic with a 100
fatality rate it was the darkest the
darkest hours
we learned that the way you change
behaviors is with narratives and
information and showing the consequences
of people's people's uh choices a little
humor a little music that's how you
change behavior not me in a box
pointing my finger at somebody it's the
opposite right so i've heard you talk
about your experience with fauci then
and and you've been i think very fair to
fouchy i would say almost overly fair
like i've been overly fair because yeah
i've been through five pandemics with
him right he was my
he was really my man during hiv
mers sars one
h1n1 h1 was a terrible pandemic you
don't even know what happened that's
what i kept saying during the outbreak i
was like that was bad and you're
worrying about this one like why didn't
we have a moderate reaction to that one
at least why this reaction anyway but uh
so i figured
he had been adulterated by the every
what everyone get adulterated with which
is the tribalism of our time and i
thought he would revert to the mean i
thought his his overall function has
always been like
his judgment has been awesome and i
would see i assume i still to this day
believe we'll see a reversion to the
mean in terms of him looking okay
however
he finally did something that upset me
which was i know if you remember him in
front of congress multiple times
whenever they would ask him about their
gain of function or
fund they've covered it he would just be
like i'm confused what are you talking
about nothing like
two days ago he goes well you know we
did fun change viral function but we
didn't not this but we were changing
violence
right that was the worst change what did
you tell us that's what we were
that's how you create vaccine hesitancy
now it's like okay i can't trust you you
knew we were asking answer the damn
question be open about this trust the
american people to be able to digest
what you're telling them and give them a
recommendation and then move on so do
you think in essence he lied under oath
to randy i don't know i don't really
have an opinion about that so much just
because change of seems to be the word
that he's you can't do that right now
you've got to be open and honest you
cannot obfuscate this is dissembling you
can't whether it's you know lying or you
know
worthy of sort of further investigation
i have no opinion it's dissembling it's
obfuscating you can't be that way now
that's how you create vaccine hesitancy
i've gotten to the point now where i'm
telling people
your problem i've talked to lots of
vaccine hesitant people your problem is
you don't know who to trust here's what
i want you to do i want you to find if
it's for the kids find a pediatrician
for it's you find an internist that you
trust and you sit down with that person
and you too
make that medical decision the way we're
supposed to make all [ __ ] medical
decisions the fact that anybody has an
opinion about what a doctor does with
his patients is offensive and disgusting
the fact that anybody has an opinion
about what joe rogan doctor does with
him that's disgusting now other
physicians can have opinions about it
and we can discuss it professionally but
for people in the world to interfere
with that relationship that is
disgusting and why people aren't more
upset about the adulteration of the
relationship between doctors and
patients i i'm i'm
gobsmacked yeah no i can see it look
i i know you pretty well off camera too
i'm pretty sure i've never heard dr drew
or my friend
say
i'm upset so so i get it so not that i
don't say it
but so you you put a pretty party on
here i find my best behavior i do all
right you know uh but so to that end i
mean i assume i've heard you talk about
a little bit are you a hundred percent
against mandates as a as a general rule
to what you just said the one thing i've
learned about matters with their doctor
one thing i've learned about medicine is
you never say always and never you just
never do that so am i against mandates
generally yes absolutely i'm against the
idea that this now i understand that we
need to do things to urge populations to
do certain things i don't see where it's
there look i was in front you've been to
france recently it's very it's only been
in france once it was in 1997. i suggest
you go back there now because it's very
interesting what's happening there
what's happening there they have same
mandates we have essentially
they apply it very differently when you
go to the louvre you can show your eu
pass or go over there and get a test if
you'd like whatever you want and or you
can show us your antibodies from your
natural immunity
rational that's not a man there's a
mandate but a rational application of a
mandate
and the really interesting thing
is the youth are fighting
like crazy so 18 to 28 year olds are in
the streets by the thousands yeah you
don't see that on cnn vive la liberte is
their call this is that i spoke to my
french is pretty good i spoke to a lot
of them because i was intrigued and like
young people not asking for more mask
wearing i might understand they were
furious and their position was look
you've educated us rightly that this
thing is not a major risk to us now
you're mandating us put something in our
bodies we may choose to do it and you
can help us make that decision if you
think it's so mandating it no
and it's it's it's echoes of 1790. i'm
telling you they will they bring up the
same language as 1790 they raise their
fists and they've got a history of
beheading over there well i don't think
this is that kind of mob action yeah but
that's going on here you know it's
called cancel culture right but but the
uh
i mean i was talking to a woman at the
ticket counter as i was leaving and i
thought oh she's about 25 i'm gonna i'm
gonna bring this up and i brought it up
started talking to her and she got she's
this big and she got out from behind the
counter she goes viva
it's so important do you understand what
they're doing to us i thought wow 25
year olds this is their idea now as
opposed to a study that was done at
stanford
where they looked at the irrationality
around signaling and masks this
researcher went up to stanford looked at
stanford students on bicycles
what percentage wearing helmets what
percentage were wearing masks yeah
60 mask
20 percent helmet hilarious this virus
does not transmit out of doors it does
not transmit out of doors even the delta
really doesn't transmit out of doors
that's insane that is an insanity
okay so there's a lot there so first are
you shocked we're here in l.a yeah it's
beautiful out every day yes
unfortunately we are here for now
you almost ran for governor by the way i
don't know if you wanted that to be the
contemplative factor yeah i was kind of
pushing you yes you were but it didn't
happen that was probably when i was here
was as close i came to making a serious
effort i think i think i called governor
schwarzenegger the next day or something
to see what his thoughts were and he
pushed me even further i was surprised
that he started talking out of it but
what stopped you at the at the end
um i need a reading for the record
because i know everyone
was before this was also before larry
elder got involved i started talking to
people about uh going to the
what they called the money class which
was a shocking thing to hear yeah
already my naive brain was exploding but
it turned out i needed some uh radiation
for my prostate cancer so i was looking
down a few weeks of radiation it would
interrupt everything we were still going
to go to france yeah and i was like you
know it's not something's telling me
this is not the right time and that was
that and the radiation is fine this is a
relatively perfunctory treatment in the
kind of prostate cancer i have and it's
like all cancers chronic illnesses that
you can live with for decades so
you are a true television professional
because when you have to make a point
you go to the camera well it's an
important point trust me i'm here
okay so so that aside uh here in l.a
when i go to the supermarket
they still want you to put the mask on
obviously to me
i'm looking at people it doesn't seem as
if anyone is even thinking anymore no
they're all walking around they kind of
everyone has this sort of glossed over
they're wearing it in the parking lot
and it's like we don't even talk there's
no why isn't garcetti giving a speech
every now and again we're thinking about
maybe taking the mask off like the ship
has sailed it's like it's over i know
the the way to manage another way to
manage vaccine hesitancy is with rewards
hey everybody get vaccined if i can get
to 80 i'm going to get rid of these
mandates we're going to open up the
schools the kids i mean there's the kids
i i did i did a you know do you
understand there's a there's a
several pediatric
psychiatric associations and hospital
associations have declared a national
mental health emergency
on kids
and somebody was asking me i was i was
lecturing a teacher's group like what
can you do what can you do to help kids
i said look what they need is
contact they need you in your presence
they need you to be on their level
listening and reflect this thing called
reflective functioning where you use
your face to reflect the emotions that
you see in the children is extremely
um
it's what we call a building affect
regulation it gets into the brain in a
way that words do not and i was thinking
about what i normally recommend for this
and some one of the teachers goes but
the masks and i thought oh my god
yeah i i i'm at a loss for work what do
you think we're doing really to to the
kids at that age when i think it might
be all we know is the number you just
look at the numbers suicide depression
substitutes it's going crazy i mean look
if you're 18 you're you're eight years
old or 12 years old a 14 year old and
you start every time you turn on the tv
or get on the internet you see your
parents are in danger your family's
gonna be destroyed you have life
of course you
eat you know that laid out early
childhood excuse me late childhood early
essence a very grandiose phase where you
believe everything's gonna happen to you
that's normal
the way to destroy their psyche is with
what we've been doing so so all right so
backing up a little bit to to fauci
forget for a second so i've been
covering this a lot and i always try to
say i'm not trying to impugn his motives
but i am starting to i honestly am i to
me he has bungled this to the point of
almost ridiculousness like literally at
the height of it telling us all to wear
masks but then emailing his friends who
were going on vacation to say the masks
you don't you buy its doors don't work
and actually then the video came out
later him telling someone else on pbs
years ago that masks actually make you
touch your face more but then he's
telling people to double mask like
there's been such a series
of crazy things that it leaves someone
like me that's fairly well educated i
talk to people like you and i watch him
and i think
the ship has sailed with this guy public
health definitely you know whoever
whatever public health official has just
boggled bungled this entirely again it
was astonishing to me i don't know why
they did what they did it doesn't make
any sense they defied everything we've
learned about changing behavior in a
pandemic and i don't know why they did i
don't get it but um there was something
you were saying oh so here's the deal
with the mask thing right so
influenza well you know the whole story
about where the where the lockdowns came
from from a high school student yeah
right it was it was something that was
never studied right it was just it was
like a joke although i saw her father
online a little while ago doubling down
that she saved millions of lives it was
the right thing to do so he who
published the paper that said local
lockdowns for influenza is a good idea
maybe
national lockdowns for a respiratory
virus we have no idea totally different
transmission right you mean that people
in rural montana maybe should have a
different reaction than people living in
midtown manhattan what i don't know what
you're talking about what's the
difference between those two populations
but but so the mask with influenza we do
recommend you don't wear it because the
hand is the primary transmission unit so
getting hands to the away from the face
is our primary goal so he was applying
the principles of influenza thinking
this was going to be like influenza i
would defend him on that what i don't
defend is the theater around
basketballing what is the efficacy of
mass do you hear anybody talking about
that no we don't anymore okay and do you
have any studies about this do you think
okay there have been two huge studies
one was the danish study and there was
tremendous excitement around this study
we couldn't wait to see a publisher and
find out how well these masks were
suddenly everyone starts passing on the
publication jama ah i can see where this
is going it's finally published in the
annals of internal medicine right it's
published and it's it shows about a 15
to 20 percent efficacy of mask wearing
which was not zero not zero but not
eighty and not a hundred percent fifteen
to twenty percent then there was a huge
study that came out of bangladesh that
was highly criticized but not a bad
study showed again 15 to 20 in that
range maybe a little less
and
that's it that seems what mass do people
behave as though they're 100 percent and
wearing them outdoors makes zero sense
like exactly none zero but indoors it's
like okay we want to do something we
want to make but to treat people like
there's some sort of
wielding a murderous weapon by not
wearing the mask again we need to
educate people about the reality of
masks you're better off just distancing
that's significantly better so i anyway
it's just so so when you talk when you
mentioned what happened at the louvre
okay so you have to have a test or you
can be tested right there or they check
your antibiotics like that like that all
sort of intellectually does make sense
to me but but where i'm at at this point
is i think emotionally it's a lot more
pleasant because they literally what do
you want what do you want to do but i
would give you something even more
emotionally pleasant to me which would
be if you've been vaccinated go in and
if you want to wear a mask wherever
that's kind of the way it is in new york
no i know it's just fine in new york
yeah i mean i was i was shocked when i
was in new york a couple weeks ago
people were just scanning they put up
wristbands
right when it started and they were
doing it and they're like don't take
your mask off get out we'll make the
staff wear it but you get out of it but
how worried are you about the
conditioning of it whether whether you
send people to go check your antibodies
or let me get this it's what adam
carolla calls crate training yes we've
all been crazy yes that is what i am far
more concerned about the mind virus more
than the the code of the house i
worry about it i i i my my i've always
been a stream moderate middle everything
and and i think i was a little more
liberal but liberal kind of left me
somehow i know the feeling yeah
and it makes me seem more right i am not
trust me i mean i spent decades fighting
the right because they were the ones not
letting me talk about hpv vaccines and
mourning after contraception i mean i
was really in conflict with the now
seems like it's coming from the other
side which is don't worry my audience
gets it it's it's very weird it's very
weird yeah um but [ __ ] i lost my train
of thought the um
well the mind virus basically and the uh
how this is so adam was just saying how
how we've all been crate trained and
that it's complete now the crate
training is complete and they don't have
to worry about i i
i i'm generally mystified i know what i
was going to say i'm generally mystified
by people that want orders from without
and the people that want to issue those
orders that's mysterious to me i
understand why
uh gavin newsom would
feel okay about this i talked to a
governor a friend of mine in another
state
who called me said they want me to put a
mask man that's not my job i don't tell
people i don't why that's not government
that's not what i should be doing he was
eventually persuaded to do it because
the pressure got so high
i i i don't
now i lost my train of thought again
this is what covert did to me
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah it gave me some
weird weird stuff
a little more i have more train of
thought trouble than aging alone used to
give me interesting it interferes with
interesting well we're talking about the
crate training aspect of it and that
basically everyone is just bowing to
demands of people who oddly want to
demand things i was going to say which
is i did one thing that i have changed
on even though i've stayed in the middle
and i'm still same ideas i've always had
i never was aware
aware
of how much i valued freedom
and how much it needed to be protected
i'd heard about that i'd laughed about
that when military people talked about
it i literally made fun of it yeah and
all of a sudden that has become a vivid
reality to me that freedom is something
to be cherished and to be defended and
we better pay attention to that and the
the masking is the opposite of that now
i'm not saying you shouldn't mask i'm
saying you should not be
taken by the mind virus if you do mask
you should be doing it because you've
decided to make a difference for that
fifteen percent effect and you're doing
the best you can not because somebody
told you to do it
so right
right so of course so the other part
then i would say the next extension of
that is the thing that i'm worried about
which is that we are now othering
i don't think we sitting in this room
but mainstream is now othering
people who are making medical choices
for themselves to the point where
they're basically saying you're diseased
which by the way if you haven't been
vaccinated it doesn't mean you have
covid but you're diseased and you're
going to potentially come kill me which
is an odd anti-vac statement by the way
if you believe the vaccines work but can
you just talk a little bit about the
psychology about that because you know
one thing that's popped up now is like
you could sort of see how the nazis did
horrible things now when you when you
other
people in a society yes well there's i
need to let me actually write stuff down
as i'm talking to you yeah we can we can
make that because what's happening is
i'm having so many thoughts at once we
can make that so there's there's one
form of othering that i spotted earlier
that i knew was going to be a problem
and that was
what they were doing in new york when
you have to have a vaccine to go to a
restaurant to go to a you know anywhere
essentially
and in new york city there was a high
degree of vaccine hesitancy in african
americans and i thought what what is
this you're creating an out group
based on based on historical treatment
of a population due to their race
there's there's a
very compelling reason black people
black folk have distrust of the medical
system they were
mis mishandled throughout much of
history god knows on the mental health
side it's even been worse and i'm not
just talking about the tuskegee
experiment i'm talking generally
medicine just look at the how we treated
the cocaine pandemic we treated that as
a criminal problem thank god i did not i
treated lots of cocaine addicts and i
treated them as people with an illness
the way we did with the opiate epidemic
point being that you create an out group
based on a historical treatment of a
population due to their skin color and
now you're telling them because of that
you're out
that is
well that's that's as racist as you can
possibly be and it's creating an out
group so there's there's now we create a
now group there
out group in the unvaccinated who get
sick they shouldn't get access to
treatment have you seen that no this is
this is extraordinary now that means
that anybody who makes a bad decision
that has an impact on their medical
condition should be prevented from
accessing medical care what happens to
my patients the drug the heroin addicts
the alcoholics they're all making bad
choices all the time
just die no no access for you
in fact you'd have to close emergency
rooms because the emergencies are filled
with people who are doing stupid [ __ ]
that's mostly what's going on people in
accidents people using drugs people not
taking their meds people i mean it's
mostly what it is and so all those
people no longer get access to medical
care is that what we're saying it's also
against the hippocratic oath this isn't
that isn't that the number one thing i'm
going to talk to arthur kaplan on monday
on my streaming show and this is what i
want to get into with him he's he's a
medical ethicist yeah
and he took the position that it was
okay not to treat
i believe that's what he concluded it
was okay for doctors not to treat
vaccinated unvaccinated people which i'm
like i can't even the premise being that
this is such an extraordinary i was
presented with i was presented with
treating there was a horrible this is
way in the late 80s we had a horrible
shootout it was an asian gang in a part
part of sort of san marino monterey park
and really an ambush on a group of
officers and these guys were animals and
they came they some of them were shot
and came to our er i had i ethically had
to treat i didn't want to of course i
thought about not doing it it was my
obligation to treat those guys and i i
thought they should they deserved i had
all kinds of horrible thoughts about
them but i treated them i did my job and
the fact that we turn away from that is
is
bizarre so we have we have
based on race
based on behavior which is how you get
bad medical outcomes and and then it's
hardening them right it's making them
into a tribe and it's hardening their
resistance by telling them they're dumb
and ignorant and don't know what they're
doing
all of them i talked to
i talked a lot of them and it's always
the same story which is i don't know who
to trust i know where to get good
information and i've been like i told
you i've been telling them to get
together with a doctor now get together
with your doctor someone you trust and
make that decision together the way
medicine has always been practiced and
by the way i will give you credit here
where it's due which is that you were
one of the first people out of the gate
probably a month in before any when
everybody was just going along with
group things lock everything down shut
everybody down scroll down and you were
one of the do you know how many weeks
that was in basically it was
right when the uh well it was actually
during the wuhan outbreak it was we
didn't even barely got into italy yet i
was saying stop using the word
staggering stop it it's not staggering
there's going to be big numbers what are
you going to
things listen to the cdc i then i was
saying listen to the cdc listen to dr
fauci they're the people whose job it is
to get us through this stuff and then
like trump derangement took off it was
like a like the new york times editorial
board had an opinion about medical
management of a pandemic they should net
they should be dis
they should be that to me that's almost
a criminal action to try to interfere
with the operation of a medical
decision-making process with an
organization multiple organizations they
scared everybody to death where my
profession froze and it was it was
astonishing to see it was such i i made
a huge mistake in buying there but in
the middle too i was comparing it to
h1n1 which was see it's it's it's a
mistake to compare one pandemic from
another but i was just trying to get
everyone just to kind of put it in
context and calm down and let's make
some good decisions look how different
this would have been if somebody had
said this is going to be awful we're
going to get through this medical
medical medical system here united
states is the best in the world we'll
flex up we'll we will it'll be a
challenge but we will get enough beds
we'll have enough ic we'll get more
ventilators and
we will find a way to a vaccine and some
treatments it's what we do best so let's
get this now for a couple weeks while we
figure things out what trump said isn't
it it's kind of it was impossible to
tell what was coming out of there
yeah well there was a lot of different
stuff coming out but in the meantime
lock it down while we figure out what's
going on see if we're right and see if
this is really something that we can
handle this way and then let's let's
let's get to keep the kids in school
like so many countries are doing i mean
let's
minimize the collateral damage from this
thing instead of maximizing the
collateral damage in retrospect do you
think it's nuts like if i think if i had
a time machine i had a delorean and i'm
going back in time
uh it's not it's not a phone booth it's
a delorean i'm back in time
in to me it seems that we should not
have locked down anything we should have
said to people wear masks if you want to
wear masks work life is going to
continue we're going to work on a
vaccine and we're just going to do the
best we can and to me no matter what the
result even if the death uptick had been
a bit more than it is right now we would
be much better off because now the
cascading problems throughout society
you've mentioned you know between work
and health and mental health and
everything else
i mean the amount of weight people have
gained there's all sorts of stuff and to
be fair some people have been through
this and and benefited like i talked to
a woman nine year old woman this morning
who said you know this thing's been a
blessing for me because i could stay
home and do these things i thought okay
i can accept that it's not all bad
uh but
and i have many friends smart friends
who say you know when i say things like
you just said they go you know we needed
to lock down we needed to figure out we
really didn't know what's going on okay
for a while but to have done it
with no end point with no goal i
remember i was you know i did a local
show here on channel 11 on fox 11 all
through the pandemic we were doing
updates every day what was going on and
we had from somebody from the school
board come in you know weekend when they
decided they were going to close the
schools and i was like how did you
arrive at this decision who were the
physicians that advise you who were the
ex we just decided to do it it's like
why how long what are the consequences
how are you you should see now the data
there's this group called gaggle that
documents the data of adverse events
from the
use of screens in terms of sexting
access to porn violent violent and uh
suicidal sort of uh musing online it's
like up 400 percent and it's up in in
elementary age as well as middle school
because we literally force them to have
their own interactions on those screens
they did nothing to protect them from
all the consequences of screens that we
know
the screen we're gonna look at the
screens the way we look at tobacco in 20
years there's no doubt in my mind but to
think think about it we gave
kids cartons of cigarettes and said this
make you feel better here you go this
will help you with your education so
instead we said to them you're not going
to school put a computer in their room
they have access to god knows what all
day on top of just the general and on
top of the isolation the fear the
you know the lack of socialization the
lack of developmental milestones and
just and lack of academic progress and
just throw our hands up well what are
you gonna do is there a psychological
term for that feeling that that first
two weeks when lockdowns were starting
where there was almost this odd
excitement like not not joy i would say
but everyone just felt like oh there's
something going on it's like a little
bit out of our mundane lives i was on
fox and i brought my dog on because i
was home and they loved my dog is on fox
it's so great i adopted a dog like there
was this feeling of like oh well it's
temporary it's this weird thing and we
all kind of i know clyde he did not he
did not sit still for a television show
all right fair enough yeah that sounds
like clyde yeah uh yeah something about
that that sort of group
i think the excitement i think there's a
certain i didn't experience that and i
think a certain percent of the
population always experiences stuff like
that when their things are dangerous
they actually get high yeah uh for me i
i use it i use the word nuclear winter
to describe that that to me felt like
nuclear winter it's like like a pall
felled over everything it was awful i i
hated it hated every second of it and i
i was not alone it was really uh
it was darkness it was really darkness
everywhere and that is not a healthy
thing for the human condition that's
about as bad as you can get and why did
we do it is the question and why are we
measuring what we did and why aren't we
sort of asking questions about what we
should do differently next right that's
it why aren't we asking any of those
questions now we're not doing any of
that it's so strange
by the way i'm not against lockdown i
think i think a temporary lockdown was
probably what we needed to do i mean
think about but here here's the thing
why we couldn't do it
because we didn't know we didn't know
but to be fair he was right not to
remember how he just made his decision
he brought in a bunch of nobel laureates
do you remember that panel he had i
don't remember specifically oh i watched
it it doesn't surprise me i watch it
he brought in three nobel laureates and
two other guys if i remember right
and he just queried them for a couple of
hours about the how this what this looks
like what the data is how this works and
he went at the anyway i see no re i can
see no compelling reason based on what
you're saying that we should lock down
they all went yeah wait so then why are
you partly for them because it was
confusing and i'm okay with people sort
of i i remember being at the time
thinking i was not against locking down
the schools that always seemed insane to
me i also was very disturbed they never
were honest with us about who was really
at risk for this thing 85 plus is really
at risk for this thing kids not at risk
and that should have been clear from the
beginning but the fact that that we
didn't really know what was going on and
i thought about at the time i thought to
myself
what if i was in this position and i was
charged with keeping everybody safe i
probably would prepare for the worst
case scenario at least for a couple of
minutes and i thought i don't think he's
right but okay i'll go along with it for
a little while never dreaming it would
go on for
ever right well that's why if i had that
time machine to me you you basically by
the time machine you basically do
nothing not not the time machine
i would advocate for distancing i would
keep kids in school
i would uh again we didn't know the
speed at which that r knot was going to
go uh
because we were we would have had we
would if we'd done nothing we would have
ended up with something like we had in
december and january of 2020
2021 rather
and that was pretty nasty that was
pretty nasty but we ended up with it
anyways the point and the virus does
what the virus does there does not seem
to be a lot that we do that really
changes the behavior of the virus what
we can change is how it affects us
that we can change make milder illness
get antivirals vaccinate that we can do
yeah should we be paying attention to
any of these other horse dewormers or
things that crazy right-wing maniacs
like joe rogan are talking about early
treatments like like can you say the
words on you i gotta put it on youtube
we're on rumble now we'll be alright
we'll be all right uh so
i don't think i i i talk to it there's
there are nodes in this pandemic for me
in terms of the the ability to be open
and honest one node was when fauci said
yeah maybe this we'll look into where
this thing came from a wuhan lab i felt
like oh now we can have this
conversation
i was talking to a pulmonologist
yesterday from the cleveland clinic and
was on a stream show
and he said well you know at the
beginning remember at the beginning of
time we all were prescribing
hydroxychloroquine and i thought oh we
can say that now right doctors
everywhere we were kicked off youtube
six months later you couldn't you
couldn't say the word these are words
this is a medicine that joy behar and
other people and don lemon had just
learned how to pronounce they just don't
pronounce it i've been using it for
decades it's one of the safest medicines
you can use and we were prescribing it
because we had nothing else to offer and
this looked like it might be helpful so
doctors routinely were prescribing it
now we can say that we can be honest
about that's what we're doing
didn't do much if anything i think
ivermectin may be a little better but
not much i think i think once you have
real treatments that's going to all go
away and you're going to have real
treatments that have real effects it's
the difference between essentially
drinking cranberry juice for urinary
tract infection versus taking scepter or
taking cipro it's it's a lot different
right you you mentioned that one of the
things that's changed you in this is
that you value freedom or you understand
the concept a little bit more
the fact that you just said uh all right
we couldn't talk about hcq yeah and and
youtube was booting people off and
twitter was getting rid of the doctors
talking about
just discussing the evidence not saying
you should do this or shouldn't do it
just discussing the evidence quite
literally quite literally doctors
100
um
how has any of this changed your
feelings on any of the big tech stuff i
know that's not totally your domain but
as someone that communicates this stuff
for a living i have no doubt that not
only online options have probably closed
in some ways but i would guess some of
the mainstream stuff right like are you
getting less calls because you're
willing to talk about i was getting
those calls for a while now it's now
that sort of
like i said there are nodes in this
thing where you can start to be honest
about this and you don't have to cancel
people if they're trying to be honest so
i am getting more opportunities to speak
right now because people want to take a
look at this and see what happened what
people's opinions are rather than
opinions being dangerous and needing
needing to be canceled which was
think about how crazy that is
have you ever been through a period of
history like this anywhere i've
personally been through it where
no no i mean you know this well you mean
just generally about canceled culture i
mean this sort of thing no i mean
we've never had anything like this
although we have had periods of extreme
polarization right you know in the 50s
some degree of like well this is the
same thing right this is very similar to
that but but usually in the face of that
kind of stuff we come up with a center
we really do whether it's teddy
roosevelt or abraham lincoln or these
are people argue people tell me abraham
was a radical he was a centrist he was
he was interested in finding a middle
path
i feel like we're going to come up with
something like that i i hope and then
the reality is that's going to be the
populist movement trump is not the
populist movement obama there's going to
be some middle much like teddy
roosevelt's in my head as the model and
something like that's going to kind of
rise up i think because there's so many
people in this country that are just are
fearful and afraid to speak their mind
and are rational people with good ideas
and wondering what went wrong with their
government right well to that point do
you think there's something else going
on with with all of us psychologically
well there is something led to this
political right so inside kovitz
specifically all right see this is a
okay uh i'm gonna have to build this
case for you all right i wrote a book on
narcissism right and the book documented
very clearly we've had a narcissistic
turn i i we have there's no argue no
disputing that anymore we've
we've had a in 1850 they debated whether
narcissistic disorder even existed
there's no debate in 2021
and i in the 80s i was working in a
psychiatric hospital and we'd have these
admitting sheets with the axis one two
and three diagnoses and access to other
personality disorders when i arrived
there in 1985 access to had all kinds of
different personality disorders
obsessive-compulsive dependent all kinds
of things antisocial and then around
1988-89 i noticed that all of a sudden
all the other personalities disorders
went away and all only cluster b's were
being admitted which are the
narcissistic disorders borderline
sociopath narcissist
histrionic those were those are the
cluster b's and that's it ever since
everyone has a cluster b disorder
now where do the cluster bees come from
they come from childhood trauma now at
the same time i was doing a love line
all and all it was every night every
call sexual abuse physical abuse neglect
i mean it was
pandemic
the 70s unleashed something
and it unleashed it on people to do it
first i took the attitude that that
children were little beings little
adults little sexual beings they just
need to express it and if some adult
predator was around it's like hey man
he's into it he wanted you know there's
a lot of horrible stuff going on for a
year and that person didn't do that once
they did it many many times and then
that child has a probability of being a
perpetrator so it was expanding rapidly
all over the place
i was hearing about it all the time when
i wrote the narcissistic book i wanted
to do a chapter on we're back to the
french revolution again i'm
pre-revolutionary france and the reason
was i was i was looking across the
historical sweep and i thought this is
not normal there's it's not as though
periods of this degree of childhood
sexual abuse is normative it's in social
even in highly distressed populations in
war in in impoverished area not this
kind of exploitation of children there
are other periods of history where this
must have happened and the only really
good one i could find was 1750 france
where where children were routinely
marginalized were abused sexually were
you know the families were broken apart
there was there was libertinism
everywhere and it was destructive to
children and then you get the french
revolution i was talking to the woman to
help me wrote the book on narcissism and
i said you remember me obsessing about
1750 france and wanting to put that in
and she was like oh yeah you were you
were hell-bent on it but the publisher
wouldn't let me say it was too
far-fetched and the point i wanted to
make was is that when there's that kind
of childhood trauma you get a lot of
narcissism and a lot of unregulated
emotions particularly aggression and
that results in collective mobs
and guillotines scapegoating
scapegoating mechanisms is what keeps
people that are
aggressive from attacking out in each
other they get together and they act out
on one i didn't know about social media
i didn't know about cancellation but
there it is that's the cancel culture so
there's the the big sweep but there's a
new wrinkle in this that i did not see
coming can i can i finish this yeah of
course
and when when i
a couple years ago i i was sitting here
and i was hearing
discourse
that to me sounded delusional and like
frankly delusional and i thought oh my
god if somebody came in my office
in 19 in 2015
and said uh you know there's nazis i
have to go kill some nazis nazis and
this is a nazi and a nazi and a nazi and
she's a nazi and oh well the government
there's russian operatives in the white
house you are being you're going to the
hospital right now i'm going to admit
you for delusional some some psychotic
disorder and i thought oh my god that is
everywhere we we are prone to
delusionality well when are people prone
to delusions when they become histrionic
so we've shifted from pure narcissism
into histrionic disorder and histrionics
are prone to getting swept into you know
sort of collective ideas they have a lot
of emotionality they have you know
extreme acting out behaviors and it's
all with us now it's what we're seeing i
don't know if the pandemic caused it or
it was something that's coming anyway
but histrionic is sort of the disorder
the the the order of the day all right
so now i think we're we're into the meat
here so when i turn on i don't i don't
have a t i don't have cable anymore but
when i see clips let's say of msnbc
during the day and they are saying the
most outrageous over-the-top white
supremacists have taken over trump is
leading the nazis for the insurrect like
to stuff that to my ear sounds you live
in an alternate reality and i talk about
on the show a lot these people live in a
different reality than me i don't know
how we immediately bring it together i
don't know how we do that so if i
if someone is watching this and they
have someone in their family that is
listening to this stuff and really
believes nazis are everywhere and all
this stuff what would you do how do we
deprotonate i i have been
obsessing about this for a few weeks now
as i've sort of crystallized these ideas
and the the only way i know of to do it
is what we call sort of reality testing
getting people back to reality keep keep
emphasizing
real numbers
real facts just keep them in reality
it's about all you can do and use
reality that isn't easy these days
because people don't trust your number
it's not easy i know i know i don't
trust them either and so that's why it's
hard but you've got to just stay with
what's real do you know any nazis have
you seen nazis or like try to stay in
the reality of the moment and the more
you get to reality the more you can
break down the delusions uh and it's
it
it's not easy and it may not even be
possible that's what worries me i i
don't know that it's possible i i do
know that the media
you know this as well as i do the people
producing the media are really just
they do something and they look at the
numbers did that create numbers or not
hey when she talked about nazis it
really got a spike in the numbers do
more of that i don't know if they
believe what they're saying or not the
problem is they're fueling delusionality
and so you have to again let's talk
about what they're doing on tv here
let's talk about the people let's look
at who's creating the information you're
looking at let's look at some
alternative ideas here you've got to
stay much like with vaccine hesitancy
you have to treat people with respect
and be very sort of um magnanimous in
your approach you have to be just sort
of hmm you know i i recommend the use of
therapeutic wonderment all the time i
wonder what they have the world were
flat i wonder
hmm i wonder how that would work with
trigonometry there i wonder i wonder how
they could get a you know something
just a lot of wondering wandering one
again just keep the reality coming in
and eventually kind of get through do
you think some of this is just sort of
like
it's almost like
at the end of a successful society
no don't talk that way well no i still
have hope believe me i have a lot of
hope i think we can get to some of the
things that you're talking about i do i
don't know that it exactly comes out of
the center but putting that aside that
it
at some stage of a liberal democracy
that is flourishing you will have
allowed in so many crazy ideas you will
have gotten so fat on freedom and doing
what you want and living as you wish
which is mostly good that then you will
have drag queen story hour you will have
the surgeon general saying that a
biological man is a female you will have
all this stuff like it's just the end
game in a way of this which as a
california
liberal i think is how you describe
yourself is a sad position to have to
defend
this is again back to keeping reality
coming in reality eventually comes to
bear
reality has a way of coming in
and you can say all the abraham lincoln
has a famous some of this must have been
going on in the civil war too because
abraham lincoln has a very
wasn't a famous quote as a quote that
caught my attention as it pertains to
our current moment
he came into the cabinet meeting one day
and he you know chase and all those guys
are there and he goes gentlemen
if i say an elephant's trunk is a leg
hear this yeah how many legs does that
elephant have and they all go five i
guess and he goes no
four calling it a leg doesn't make it a
leg and i thought that's this moment you
can call you can say anything you want
it doesn't make it so you're trying to
make it so
it won't be it just isn't you can't make
things so but there is interesting thing
you said here too also which is you
talked about the the limits of freedom
at the same time as we're sort of
defending freedom i'd not really thought
about that because in a way the way we
got here is because
of sort of
ex in a weird way excessive freedom to
the point that reality was was uh
subjugated you know it's more freedom to
instead of freedom from right so you
want freedom from well it reminds me of
excuse me you're right it reminds you of
the the tolerance and intolerance it's
intolerance the name of tolerance it's
it's a weird this is a weird spot uh i
do feel though that the excesses of
freedom and brought us to the place
where freedom from yes needs to be
defended so uh
i know that the
well this we're actually all bouncing
around through a lot of the stuff that's
in your book it is in the book but let
me just say that if the book is
written by me and my daughter uh she is
very woke uh and she actually
helped me understand some of her point
of view i really got to a better
understanding of where she sees these
things
and it's designed for a 15 year old and
their parents essentially it's something
you should leave out on your coffee
table if you have middle late teenagers
how to navigate relationships it was
originally about consent
because back when we before covet
consent was something and the heels the
metoo movement was a very very important
conversation and adolescents were very
confused about it we realized as we
wrote the book it really is about how to
navigate relationships generally so so
to that point so you just described your
daughter as woke which i think a lot of
people are watching this in fact in fact
we were on megyn kelly and megan went i
think you're the first woke person i've
ever had on this show and because she
launched into her patriarchy thing oh
yeah and uh and megan megan was great
she was very gracious and she pushed
back and we had a nice nice that that's
good that's a night that exactly and
then my daughter i shouldn't be on these
kinds of shows like if you want to make
your point where you want to make it to
the echo chamber make it to megyn kelly
that's where you should be making it if
you want to if you want to bring people
on board with your point of view what
kind of tension has that caused you
because every night every single person
watching this is going through some
version of that myself including for
sure i've got someone woke in your
family um it actually really improved
our situation because i think there was
a
we were forced to
really clarify our positions to one
another by talking to somebody else and
uh i it helped me help me and by the way
i started admiring how she thought about
things you can admire people that have
ideas that are different than yours i i
don't i feel like for her reality will
come in a little more and she'll adjust
this something but i i admire what she's
thinking about and that she's struggling
with these things and i get it i get it
i don't agree with it but i get it and
so that's that's how i would approach it
so without making this about her
specifically although if you want to
generally speaking if you were to say to
a woke person there are biological
differences between you'd have to you'd
have to be using your females you'd have
to say look i'm not a biological
determinism you'd have to find the just
get the common ground quick just go look
i agree gender is a construct and it's
not about strictly the biology but and
i'd actually put this in the book this
is this is where i was pushing back kind
of hard in the book i was like i'm a
physician right yeah i i have to know
the the sex hormones and what they're
doing biologically i have to know that
and by the way if i'm going to deal with
the transgender they're getting very
powerful medication from maybe me that
are hormones that are not being produced
because of the
hormone because of the chromosomal
situation that's a medical treatment i
need to know what i'm doing and that's
my main that's actually my main thing
about
treatment and transgender right now is i
don't think my profession is doing a
good job the job should be the right
treatment for the right patient at the
right moment and we have not figured
that out they're all getting everything
the same and that is never as good
that's never what do you think happened
i guess at the the psychiatric layer
when it comes to this i'm guessing i'm
not psyched i'm talking about i'm just
talking about push all that aside and
just say somebody's going to get
treatment
that you know when do you do it and who
do you give it to who's the right one to
give it to and how do you determine that
that none of that is just everybody gets
the treatment no questions asked that's
it that's not how you do medicine right
so then what happened okay so more
broadly and what happened at the medical
layer where you know
the same thing that you talk about same
thing
same thing that happened
uh during coven same thing to happen is
my physician freezes they freeze and
they're afraid to do anything they're
afraid to say anything so i something i
didn't know until covet is that so many
of my peers are
employees now so they're fearful of
doing something out of line for their
employer they're that's interesting so
there's less that just have their own
almost because
it doesn't exist so if you say something
wrong the employer will fire you i've
talked to doctors that have been fired
for saying something online that didn't
fit the orthodoxy of the institution
as well as a fear of the canceled
culture and fear of people coming after
them and feeling people encumbering
their license i mean they're scared
doctors are so easily scared that's how
we end up with the opioid epidemic
because doctors started getting
criminally prosecuted for inadequate
treatment of pain
they were getting fined and going it's
not malpractice that's criminal and
civil liability and we all froze we we
stopped prescribing for pain patients
and sent them all to the pain management
people and their position was
pain is what the patient says it is pain
controls what the patient says it is you
don't even need a doctor just ask the
patient what they need and set it set it
off the counter will have the starbucks
point of what you want they were doing
that in florida at one point and that's
how you got the opioid epidemic so
relating this to the to the trans issues
it's one of the issues of the day and
yeah and since you were talking to your
daughter i mean we seem unable to have
that basic thing but i get it you can
you can have there are soft ways to have
it i know you know somebody can get into
it then once you're into it you're going
to disagree on that sure but when you
see the surge i don't know if you saw it
the surgeon general of the united states
sending out a tweet that rachel levine
is our first four star female blah blah
blah
she i'll use her preferred pronouns
because i'm a nice guy she's not female
but you see the surgeon generally i get
i get there there's a
there's a lot of orthodoxy around the
language did she say female or female or
woman female that's the part because
that's the part i i have trouble with
the female part i mean because because i
have no i have no problem with calling a
transgender woman a woman i have no end
because she i'm not i agree
but if when you start saying you know
you start trying to trying to adjust the
biology it's like
that and then i'm then i'm concerned
that then it's like how do i treat this
person how do i know what i'm dealing
with i mean i
do i do i as a gynecologist should i be
treating men is that as a pro as a as a
as a urologist should i pretend that
women have a prostate
screen them for prostate cancer because
they want me to
i hate to tell you what i think most of
their answers would be you've got to be
kidding
not really no no no no listen i am very
concerned about transphobia and about
the la i don't want those people to i
don't want anybody with those people i
don't want anybody with any conditions
to feel marginalized or not a part of i
want everyone to get along that's my
thing and so you know people want to use
certain language i'll try to figure it
out i'll try to go with it but i'm a
biologist and there's certain things i
just have to have in order to do my work
that's all so are you surprised how
woke
the hard sciences became that two plus
two doesn't always equal i always
thought that that weren't i always
thought that would not happen that was
shocking to me i still think that will
quickly come back that can only happen
for so long before science doesn't work
well how quick i mean well the question
always is then what kind of destruction
can they do i know but they will be
quietly doing what they do it's just
that's just
what it is
you can't do it otherwise
what else is on your mind these days
um
in in this just craziness that we seem
to be in it is craziness i i cause it
does seem like a mass psychological
disorder that we're all going through
and you're a public person in the midst
of all of you yeah that's what i mean it
feels like your life sort of led to this
oh it's been very
unpleasant it's been terribly unpleasant
but i feel like my job is to really keep
walking through it but but i got to tell
you the only thing i would say is i i'm
leaning on philosophy a lot right now i
think that's i think stoicism has
remarkable utility right now stoicism is
like a
like a anti-viral
sort of uh system for our cognitive
systems it we have lots of glitches in
our cognitive system it's some of what's
going on here is that people don't know
how to reason don't i think know how to
assess things and stoicism adjusts the
the cognitive processes very nicely
the other thing is i'm kind of i didn't
know i would ever become this way but i
find myself being a little bit hegelian
in the sense that which he didn't
actually say this but there's a
construct around his thinking is that
there's a antithesis
a thesis an antithesis and then a
synthesis and i feel like we're in some
sort of antithetical movement now that
will bring good things i'm trying to say
positive that there'll be good things
that come of it and we'll have some sort
of synthetic function that will uh get
us through this you said something to me
as we were walking in here today that
made me
worried that that that that that process
will not take hold but that tends to be
how did i say
well i was we were talking about cities
in this country and our concerns about
them and what a disaster they are and
you said well that's the plan yeah just
to approve
yeah well
i don't know that that's counter to the
to the idea that it's just that i
believe that the intentions of these
people related to their policies if you
defund police and then you increase
crime and then murder goes up and you
look at the data and you keep doing it
my my belief is that their intentions
are to destroy some of these cities to
prove in their minds that capitalism
doesn't work thus they can usher in
whatever it is that they want to
that's that's different that's sort of
pure i get it that's really antithesis
antithesis
that's you know and we were talking
about anarchists when we walked in here
we were talking about uh michael malus
and things like that but uh
that
whenever ideology prevails humans suffer
okay
we need a pragmatic party we need a
pragmatic system that's based on the
human reality what human how humans work
what our motivational systems are the
one thing is when you sit in the middle
you can finally see the excesses on both
sides and one of the things i keep
seeing on the
progressive side is they seem in total
denial of how humans work and what our
motivational systems are and how how
humans are and i don't mean just this
historical moment just the i mean i've
worked for years with humans with all
kinds of broken motivational system i
know how our brain works and our
emotional systems work i know how our
interpersonal industry intersubjective
experiences are supposed to go
they're in they're just in abject denial
about that and history is replete
with uh examples of when ideology
becomes the prevailing
principle that people get harmed
massively wasn't there a guy in germany
in the 30s who thought he was the
biggest victim of all time and then
something bad look you could i
i i hate that that guy's brought up all
the time you could bring up all kinds of
other people throughout history they've
done the same thing and it's it's it's
um it's interesting that we're getting a
little lesson on how that can happen one
of the things that was shocking to me
this is one thing that i think
malice was saying when he was talking to
jordan peterson or jordan peterson was
saying it
was that um
we deputized people during this pandemic
to to be
um an authority
you know so anybody because i i remember
i i got covet in my humble opinion
by trying to get the vaccine
at a time so so i was treating lots of
covenant patients i was still operating
my outpatient practice
and my hospital started offering the
vaccine and i went i got to get this
vaccine so i made an appointment i went
in
and when i went in
a
28 year old guy started screaming at me
where where are your papers i mean it
was like a border crossing scene from a
second world war film yeah and and i and
i was i was sort of stunned and uh and
he started you know yelling at me and i
thought
i've been a staff member at this
hospital for 35 years you you treat
senior stalwart do you like this it was
so confusing to me how does this feel
good to do this
yes it does that's how people
do that they and so didn't have the
right papers i'd run all over the
hospital i was in many poorly ventilated
rooms i thought this is how i'm going to
get covered three days later sick and
they wouldn't get me the vaccine because
first they had to
even though i made the case i said i'm
treating covet patients i'm volunteering
in the er i want to help with this
problem
we have employees that are in they're
really at higher really we gotta we got
to be fair and we have to give it to our
employees first before so the gardeners
and everybody else got it before me and
i got sex the gardener got it everywhere
everybody before me that was somebody
that did not like one of your tv shows
perhaps all right so in our last couple
minutes here i think we've we've pieced
together a decent sort of
psychological picture of what's going on
in the united states i'm still
mystifying well maybe a little bit but i
do want to give the devil his due here
okay uh obviously i'm much more critical
of the left obviously i can talk about
the woke stuff all day uh but when you
talk about some of the personality
disorders that are maybe happening over
there or they don't really understand
human nature i just say over there it's
all of us okay so now that's what i want
you to do then so give me some of that
on the right it's all of us there's
something maybe that i'm not seeing
that's more broadly happening on the
right i see the same excesses on both
sides yeah uh it's just that one right
now is sort of more in charge and more
sort of um in involved with our everyday
life you know we were having
interactions with people yelling i
walked by somebody i ran by somebody who
when i wasn't wearing a mask i was out
running and the guy was like
like that's that kind of thing i don't
see that stuff from the right i see this
so what am i not seeing there then if it
is i get it they have more culture i
wanted that now so it feels louder i
wonder that same thing myself you know
what what am i not seeing
that uh i i would say
you know usually on the right rigidity
is more of the problem there's more
openness on the left and more rigidity
on the right
and and the rigidity can go towards
excess
i i've seen some of our friends say
things
where i get the same my butt muscles
tighten up in a similar fashion like i
don't think you really mean that and i
don't say anything right i don't say
anything to them either about
their early treatments or you know what
they're thinking about the virus or
vaccines or anything like that it's like
you're entitled to your opinion that
that's fine um if you want me to talk to
me i'm available right kind of thing i
guess i guess for me the fundamental
difference would be that for whatever
rigidity is there and of course of
course it is if you're if you're more
conservative by nature sort of a lesson
to change okay but to me it's like in a
time when the world is just spinning off
the cliff because of this craziness but
it makes them more a little rigidity
okay and it makes them more real yeah no
i agree a little is that is i'm i'm up
for it but but but the virginity can
have a problem too
uh and and that crew and i think that in
there creates some of the
the funny thinking and and there's a um
what is it over there that bothers me
that could get out of control
you might my favorite try to find it i
i'm trying yeah yeah we should keep an
eye out for the question
because you know why they're everyone's
in hiding right now so we really i see i
see glimpses of it it pops out in
parties and things or something where
everyone just goes okay
and and i'm thinking where does that go
when it gets to be i think my fear is
there'll be
you know there'll be retribution and
guillotines on that side too
that's my fear so if the if the right
can not do that and stay focused on some
pragmatic solutions and staying positive
and getting everybody in the on the ship
it will be much to everyone's advantage
the problem is the pendulum seems to go
both ways and i'm fearful that and the
same processes are going on there that
that elsewhere
it's just just
different themes
different things it's it's very
concerning i'm very worried about it but
i but i remain optimistic and
that's just me i'm always optimistic
about people i love people and i feel
like especially americans i i my big
push would be to try to get us under the
under the umbrella of what got us all
here in the first place why did my
ancestors come here yeah why did why did
my
family run away from the ukrainian
genocide thank god why did they avoid
the the bolsheviks and the and the
tsarist all three were getting on my
family's case and by the way i i get
recall i'm called anti-immigrant yeah
again [ __ ] you
because my family escaped a genocide
that you one of the ones you guys have
all forgotten about so uh we they came
here because of an idea
and we have to get clear about that idea
again and we have to value that idea
again i feel like that's what's under
attack really when you get right down to
it that the the the principles the idea
that those those geniuses yes they were
old white men they were some slave
owners and there were some horrible
things
hamilton was a screwball but but but
there was there was a extraordinary
set of ideas put forth at that time that
have been the umbrella for multiple
generations of humans from multiple
regions of every region of the world and
multiple ethnicities to get along into
an uncanny degree
and and lead good lives if we just get
back to that the basics and i'm not
saying brainwash everybody and stand up
and pledge allegiance every day i'm not
saying that just expose everybody to
those good ideas and agree that they're
good ideas and see if we can live under
that those principles drew i know you're
a tv pro because not only do you look at
the camera when you make a point or do
it right i don't even have to tell you
we can't end depressingly we have to end
positively and do it it's good to see
you my friend
appreciate it if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell